E aí
a autoestima e amor-próprio parecem
atributos que a gente pode ter apenas
com força de vontade não é que basta
alguém nos falar para a gente se amar e
pra gente ter auto-estima que isso
simplesmente vai acontecer como se fosse
uma mágica Flynn e Acontece uma
transformação instantânea Pode parecer
também que aquelas pessoas que se
mostram tão perfeitas nas redes sociais
são felizes o tempo todo tem uma vida
perfeita um amor próprio e uma
autoestima inabalável não é mesmo e que
foi assim que conseguiram com força de
vontade por que a pessoa simplesmente
decidiu ouviu ou leu algo assim e por
isso eu desse jeito se a gente não toma
cuidado a gente simplesmente olha e de
alisa e não questionam não questiona
primeiro se é verdade porque o que é
mostrado é apenas um recorte da vida da
pessoa e se for se a gente conhece de
perto e é assim mesmo
o questiona como isso se deu como foi
possível nem ao menos levamos em conta
que é impossível comparar-se com alguém
você temos histórias de vida totalmente
diferentes só nos comparamos com os
outros nos julgamos por não conseguirmos
ser iguais assim tão plenos e felizes e
nos convênios e é por isso que eu vim
aqui trazer para vocês sobre a luz da
psicanálise Como pode se dar essa
verdadeira e não ilusória construção da
autoestima e do amor próprio para depois
a gente refletir O que que a gente pode
fazer com isso então vamos lá
auto-estima e amor-próprio são
construídos das nossas primeiras
relações a figura materna é o primeiro
espelho no qual o bebê se enxerga e
dependendo do que ele vai enxergar nesse
espelho ele vai internalizar esse olhar
e vai passar se olhar desse modo ele é
sentido percebido o corpo ele é olhado
bem visto Amado desejado reconhecido o
ele é e os pesado mal visto indesejado
eu não tô falando esporadicamente mas na
maioria das vezes então só é uma si
mesmo que foi Amado pelo outro primeiro
e aprendendo a te amar pode ser depois
amar os outros também é assim que se
constrói o verdadeiro amor próprio e uma
boa autoestima é tão bem sendo
reconhecido que se aprende a se
reconhecer e depois vai reconhecer o
valor do outro sem isso o reconhecimento
do outro para conosco não terá valor
algo soar como mentira e falsidade
quando chega pra nós pelos registros que
foram feitos então nas primeiras
relações haverá uma época interno
identifique o reconhecimento que
recebemos de fora ou simplesmente não
haverá com as figuras iniciais materna e
paterna que podem ou não ser os pais é o
melhor caminho pois são os primeiros
registros que o ser humano faz de si
mesmo através do Olhar do outro que faz
de quem é o outro e de o mundo interno e
externo
Silvério Então essa experiência Inicial
suficientemente boa o sujeito aprender a
te amar a se reconhecer a ter uma boa
autoestima e depois poderá fazer isso
pelo outro também amar reconhecer Este
Mar caso esse não seja possível nas
primeiras relações pode acontecer até
experiência com outras figuras
futuramente que permitam que se sinta o
que é e o que vem a ser de fato uma
relação nutridora do próprio psiquismo e
ensino e com a experiência do vínculo e
do verdadeiro amor o que é ser amado se
amar e amar o outro então vamos lá no
início até aquela figura materna teve
uma boa experiência com a sua própria
figura materna ou com outro vínculo
nutridor ela poderá fazer isso para o
seu bebê também e ele como adulto poderá
ter grandes chances de conseguir fazer
isso com seu filho futuramente
e se dá esse investimento emocional no
bebê o cuidador abre mão temporariamente
de um tanto de investimento psíquico
devido portanto em si mesmo e dividir o
suficiente com esse bebê até ele se
constituir psiquicamente a ponto de se
sentir um sujeito inteiro depois de um
tempo uma parte dessa libido que foi
tirada desse investida no bebê poderá e
deverá ser retomado inclusive para que
se beber não se sinta a vossa Majestade
o bebê para sempre que entenda que
existem outras pessoas que também tem
necessidades próprias além das dele
inclusive da própria figura materna
é mas como ele nesse ponto já se suprir
um tanto e já internalizou o que é digno
de ser amado ele vai levar consigo essa
sensação que o ajudará durante a vida
ter uma boa autoestima e amor-próprio
vai levar dentro desse simbolicamente se
a experiência foi nutridora e não mais
precisará estar grudado numa relação
concreta pois essas figuras de amor não
poderiam estar mais sempre junto ao do
lado de fora mas estarão então do lado
de dentro agora se não houve essa
experiência Inicial nem configura uma
terna nem com a paterna e nem com
ninguém de uma forma suficientemente boa
esse sujeito vai ficar a vida inteira
procurando esse olhar de amor e
reconhecimento do outro seja nas
relações de trabalho procurando ser
sempre o destaque para ser reconhecido
Nem que tenha que puxar o tapete do
outro
Olá seja uma relação de amizade nas
quais não suportará divididas com outros
amigos sem se sentir menos Amado seja
nas relações amorosas nas quais o
partido terá que ser tudo para ele
aquele que vai suprir todas as suas
necessidades o que claramente tem tudo
para sobrecarregar empinar relação
porque a gente sabe que ninguém consegue
ser tudo para alguém
e inclusive quando esse sujeito se expõe
nas redes sociais ele vai buscar o
número de seguidores e amigos nas
curtidas comentários mensajes que alguém
mostre isso para ele esse amor e
reconhecimento para ver se assim ele
consegue acreditar só que como não há
registro psíquico Inicial que eu faço
identificar como algo conhecido ele pode
ficar dependente cada vez mais disso
porque tem que ser algo concreto e nunca
será o suficiente porque ninguém
consegue viver isso 24 horas
ininterruptamente e porque essa busca
constante Por que não foi uma construção
interna não houve uma simbolização da
experiência concreta de dentro para fora
vivido uma experiência com outro ser
humano que eu fizesse sentir realmente
Amado reconhecido e valorizado
suficiente para que ele mesmo pudesse
vir a fazer isso por ele depois então
precisa mudar esse registro construído
inicialmente sim para ter uma boa em
cima e um amor próprio verdadeiro
precisa seja com outros vínculos
saudáveis ou seja não tem com saudável
dentro de uma psicoterapia
o vínculo no qual ele questione tudo que
ele já recebeu anteriormente como algo
ruim e que ele não vai mais querer que
seja assim que não serve mais para ele e
que o faça acreditar que ele é digno sim
de receber algo muito melhor digno de
receber amor de reconhecimento por ser
quem é sendo assim ele pode vir então a
ter condições de reconhecer as suas
qualidades e também de olhar com
Realismo para suas limitações tem esse
crucificar por isso pois já aprendeu que
não deixará de ser amado amado por ser
imperfeito já que todos somos
qualidades estas que quando a gente
entende que as melhores são as internas
porque as externas mudam com o tempo
me ajuda nessa construção do amor
próprio na medida em que a gente toma
fóssil dela sem arrogância foi sentimos
de verdade que somos pessoas legais e
não superiores e inferiores a ninguém
a outra questão que atrapalha construção
da autoestima são atitudes muito
críticas dos pais que a gente acaba
internalizando e passam a ser nossas em
relação a nós mesmos a entrada na
adolescência também pode ser um período
difícil pois os adolescentes não
costumam pegar leve com outros
adolescentes Ainda mais quando se tem
experiências de bullying não é
aliado a tudo isso a cobrança da mídia
por um padrão único de Beleza pode fazer
muito mal para quem já não tem uma
auto-estima muito boa a autoestima o
amor próprio portanto não nascem conosco
não surgem de um pensamento positivo ou
de um simples desejo e nem copiando
ouvindo e lendo o outro no Instagram mas
sim após temos uma relação saudável e
nutridora com outro ser humano seja um
terapeuta ou não mas que nos faz
acreditar pela vivência de extremos
dignos de sermos amados só assim teremos
amor próprio e autoestima o que não for
assim o que for apenas ouvido de fora
para dentro Pense positivo você pode ser
o que quiser só depende de você só basta
ter força de vontade e acreditar e se
amar ou olhado no outro para tentar
copiar vai acabar mais rápido do que a
chama de um fósforo do tamanho pequeno
obrigada